you know i think it was gk chesterton
who said uh
men are men
but man is a woman
and uh if you really want to do inner
work if you really want to go to the
core
of why the world is so screwed up
it's because the male ego
is just run riot
and
feminism as a political agenda as a
horizon of transcendence has only begun
to be explored
[Applause]
i really think that it's impossible to
stress enough how important how
important it is to feminize
the planet and to feminize ourselves
it's hard to put it across to people
because even
people
think that they have dealt with this
issue and they say well
you know we always go dutch what are you
talking about
that's not what i'm talking about
there really has to be a recognition of
the fact
and this gets me into more controversy
everything leads to controversy
but i really
feel that monotheism
is a horrible
error
a nightmarish
misunderstanding
not bad as a philosophical position i
mean the drive for unity but even a
phrase like drive for unity is so laden
with male chauvinist assumptions
that uh you have to wonder
uh
monotheism presents us with a model of
god
that is all-powerful
all-knowing
omniscient
and not to be questioned
well you don't have to have spent much
time reading young
to realize that our gods
are images
that give us permission
concerning how we construct our
personalities
and if you meet someone
who is all-powerful
omniscient
omnipotent and never wrong
you're dealing with a horse's ass of
some sort
you know because nobody is like that
and yet that is the
personality model that we are given
permission
to exemplify
and all men or i don't want to say all
men but most men including myself
go whole hog for this
and and most women also
i mean uh
this talk about empowering women
it to me is saying make them more
masculine we don't need to empower
anybody we have enough the problem is to
disempower the creeps that have all the
power not to hand the power over to some
other group
so i think that the real
planetary transformation of all the
political institutions and this would
solve the problem of feeding people i
mean women do not sell their breast milk
to their children it would solve uh
the problem
of uh destroying the earth women rarely
set their houses on fire it would solve
the problem of war war is apparent
abhorrent to women this is why giving
them political power has always been
such a touchy thing because they might
try to grab the rules and change the
rules of engagement
and
women
are present
to wash the bodies of the dead
to give birth
to new people they're always there at
the nitty-gritty
and men
uh through
the accident or design of biology play a
somewhat peripheral role
uh in things the proof of this is the
parthenogenetic
adaptations of lizards where there are
no males
you know they just it was so ancillary
that it was eliminated
so be forewarned as we enter the era of
genetic engineering
and the pre-monotheistic model was
philosophically messy i grant you
it was
it was that there were many gods and
many goddesses all of nature was alive
it was bathed in mystery its measure
could not be taken and birth and death
and migration all these things came in
their time it was a kind of taoistic
recognition of the plurability
of being of the multiplicity
of being and then
this fusion
into the male dominated family
and
the emergence of language in a species
with a male hierarchy has just created a
tremendous empowerment of the of the
male ego and
we're not talking about the guys hanging
out down at the pool hall i mean i deal
with people all the time who define
themselves as enlightened cleared and so
forth and they're carrying around
immense amounts of male chauvinism
and unexamined attitudes in
in the way they behave and
some of you who are at ojai may have
heard me say
a man may be a fool and not know it but
not if he's married
and this this is a clue
as to where spiritual guidance should
come from
i mean
we've run it for 15 000 years
so now why not just
stand
slightly aside and listen
with a slightly greater degree of
attention
this will
then give permission for this
nurturing a
kind of
mothering
morphogenetic field to make its impact
felt rather than this
divisive sharp edged
competitive kind of model
[Applause]
[Music]
you